qu'est-ce qu'on dit bienvenue chez vous
Christelle et ses enfants peuvent enfin
voir clairement tout ce qui était
entassé dans leur maison le résultat de
dizaines d'années sans jamais rien avoir
trié
apparemment la rentrée scolaire elle est
décalée
j'ai vu passer ça partout sur Tik Tok je
sais pas si c'est vrai j'arrive même pas
à savoir si c'est vrai ou si c'est faux
bon bah nous on a la réponse c'est
complètement faux je demande désolé
stop selon l'expression quand il y a
beaucoup d'agitation pour pas grand
chose c'est une tempête dans un
stop une tempête dans un camping dans un
camping
une tempête dans un camping nous avons
compté
635 peluches 262 produits ménagers 121
sec
482 DVD 136 paires de chaussettes et 51
chaussettes orphelines
le choc la rentrée est-elle vraiment
décalée si tu viens de te réveiller
c'est la new zen par manquer de la
semaine je vais pas vous faire attendre
plus que ça la réponse est oui cette
vidéo a été vue plus de 2 millions et
demi de fois à tel point que le
gouvernement a dû démentir lorsqu'on va
décaler la rentrée scolaire au 18
septembre et ben non évidemment que non
par contre si vous êtes au collège vous
aurez une heure de français ou de maths
en soutien par semaine de plus bon bah
voilà
ils ont aussi sans s'en rendre compte
constituer un stock phénoménal de
papeterie
je fournis l'école là en fait 209
cahiers 34 trousses 48 tubes de colle et
1153 stylos en effet au vu du conseiller
aux politiques actuel entre la Chine et
la Russie et des fortes tensions
Emmanuel Macron s'est vu dans
l'obligation de réintégrer le service
militaire via le cursus scolaire toutes
ces informations étaient rendues
possibles à ce site Actu du jour.fr qui
a rendu public un document accepté entre
Emmanuel Macron et les préfets parlant
de tout ce que je vous ai dit donc
maintenant dis-moi dans les commentaires
est-ce que cette nouvelle rentrée au 18
septembre t'arrange ou te déplaît
le jeune le jeune parle vite l'auteur de
la vidéo le voici un jeune de 19 ans qui
assume l'infobidon une blague dit-il il
propose de la relayer sur les réseaux si
vous ennuyez si vous avez du mal à vous
faire des amis notre application elle
est là elle vous permet de créer une
communauté et de vous dire on est là
pour vous vous allez plus vous ennuyer
et on peut s'amuser vous savez faire la
baleine alors là j'ai hâte c'est vrai OK
[Rires]
sur son compte l'influenceur invite donc
à diffuser l'infobidon du 18 septembre
sur une application mission du jour
contre
rémunérations c'est le principe même de
l'application mission du jour le concept
c'est quoi une mission par jour et si tu
la valides tu gagnes des token
conversables en argent réel ce qui poste
des vidéos peuvent recevoir des token en
clair des points de l'argent
[Applaudissements]
on a envie de voir le chameau le chameau
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quelle mission faut-il réaliser des
canulars
[Musique]
du jour mais le plus de post-it dans le
dos d'un ami avant qu'il ne se rende
compte
dans un restaurant demande s'ils ont une
table puis prend littéralement une table
pour prendre une table c'est bon
[Musique]
hier dans tous les lycées de Russie les
élèves de première et de terminale ont
découvert leur nouveau manuel d'histoire
avec deux nouveaux chapitres consacrés à
l'intervention militaire lancée par
Vladimir Poutine en Ukraine des
chapitres sans nuances très partisans
qui affirme par exemple que
l'intervention militaire était le seul
moyen d'éviter que l'Ukraine n'entraîne
la Russie dans un conflit avec l'OTAN
qui aurait menacé la civilisation
humaine qu'on apprend le cas d'un papa
aujourd'hui interdit de voir sa fille la
cause un dessin un dessin effectué par
sa fille il y a plusieurs mois sa fille
la voici elle a 13 ans dans son collège
les invités étaient invités au début de
la guerre à faire des dessins en soutien
à l'armée russe son dessin à elle
raconte la presse internationale
représentée les drapeaux ukrainiens et
russes avec cette inscription non à la
guerre gloire à l'Ukraine ce qui peut
paraître banal en France ne l'est pas du
tout évidemment en Russie celui qui aime
son pays ne peut l'aider à progresser si
l'eau se négliger le moindre de ses
compatriotes
et il faudrait aussi parler des dessins
animés notamment des dessins animés
japonais qui sont exécrables qui sont
terribles
merci madame de votre je suis rentré à
la maison oui prise de 300 amis m'a dit
maman je te casse la tête alors je lui
ai dit bon ben j'espère que tu vas me la
recoller après
voilà
professeur voile dessin elle va
immédiatement référé à la directrice qui
aurait fait immédiatement à la police
qui convoque immédiatement le père la
police examine ses réseaux sociaux et
découvre qu'il est hostile à la guerre
du coup on est en Russie procès immédiat
pour l'homme qui est conduit à 32000
roubles d'amende puis il est placé en
isolement et sa fille intègre un centre
de réinsertion sociale alors les centres
de réinsertion sociale en Russie c'est
quelque chose un foyer donc presque un
an que ce père est privé de contact avec
sa fille il risque aujourd'hui trois ans
de prison et toi parfois tu dis des gros
mots
c'est quoi le pire des gros mots
elle dit quoi encore
quand il s'agit de râler ils sont
champions hors catégorie feignant non
les Français
[Rires]
quant à la tournée de Michel Sardou qui
commence en octobre 100000 billets sont
partis en 8 heures et pour ses adieux il
ne compte pas faire les choses à moitié
il va y avoir des effets c'est bien
simple j'ai presque envie de me tendre
rouge et de faire comme Mylène Farmer tu
vois
je vis debout est-ce que tu pisses
debout est-ce que je puisse de vous
oui oui je pisse debout mais je
réfléchis à pisser assis en fait de plus
en plus franchement c'est trop cool il y
a moins d'accident en fait il y a moins
[Rires]
c'est extraordinaire je suis
sur les fesses